[Music]
this is our first day here we are
finding wood in Atlanta and it's it's
actually pretty unbelievable day one of
what promises to be a year of fun-filled
lensing I remember actually going to see
the first Avengers was one of my best
mates from home and I'd never have
dreamed that I'd ever be in one of these
movies let alone playing spider-man I
feel like I'm on top of the world
because this is just mind-blowing hey
everybody
James Gunn just did the best possible
thing ever he explained all the secrets
of guardians of the galaxy too as well
as infinity war big crossover points so
I cut this down to like the 10 15
biggest things that he talked about I've
changed the giveaway the Marvel giveaway
is now for the spider-man action figures
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'll announce a new winner at the
end of this so here's the James Gunn
video I'll put all into context at the
end especially Adam warlock stuff are
you contributing to the Guardians
characters involvement in the next
Avengers movie yes very very very much
so was there ever talked of Robert
Downey jr. making a cameo as Tony Stark
no there was not people are asking
infinity war stories so do we see Tony
Stark getting some mp3 player to Peter
quill with the million songs no an
infinity war no spoiler for fringe
anyone any possibility Robert Downey jr.
will star in guardians of the galaxy vol
3 no do I know who the bad guy will be
in guardians 3 yes
how many guardians of the galaxy films
are we expecting here with this
iteration of the guardians of the galaxy
there will be three movies so the next
movie is the final film for this
iteration of the guardians was Peter
egos last child to have been delivered
are there more out there somewhere well
I think that's something to think about
I also do love the character of Adam
warlock and in my original draft of the
movie Adam warlock was a major character
I ended up taking out Adam warlock
because there were simply too many
characters and and when I added one
extra major character like that it was
just too many yeah I think it's also
important to add that Adam warlock will
not be an infinity war
that is a spoiler for Adam you know at
the end we are teasing Adam warlock he
will have a future in the MCU but will
it be with an infinity war it will not
it's not it's just not going to be the
case they made me promise to spread the
word on that when I added in more like
to the end of the movie so that people
aren't expecting him into any more
if Marvel had full movie rights to all
of its characters specifically Galactus
and Silver Surfer were the guardians
movies have changed it all and there's a
chance that I would have done Annihilus
is a villain in one of the movies was
there ever a draft of volume 2 where
Thanos was going to appear no I never
put nanos and volume 2 I think vanos is
going to get plenty of screen time in
you know in in the next Avengers movie
and I didn't think that this movie was
about that I love the Stan Lee cameo
what made you think of the cameo for him
well I actually read a you know the
Marvel fan sites and the Marvel message
boards out there and a lot of times
people have ideas that are somewhat
off-base or silly or whatever but one
thing I found very funny and interesting
was the fact that people thought Stan
Lee is a watcher and yes I know I made a
mistake
so people have written and asked me and
I'll own up to my mistake because
guardians of the galaxy vol 2
theoretically happens in 2014 which is
before infinity war and Stan Lee in the
movie says that time I was a FedEx guy
which is what he is in civil war and I
screwed up I wasn't thinking that's
that's all that is but I'm going to say
that probably Stan Lee used the guise of
a FedEx guy more than one time when on
the day with Stan what I did was I just
kept yelling out different things that
he had done in the different cameos and
including I was a DJ at you know I was a
DJ at a strip club that time I was a DJ
- strip club which is what he was in
Deadpool which I thought would have been
interest
because that would have sort of slightly
linked the Fox and MCU universes will we
see a bigger role in guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 with the original group
under stack are at the end of the movie
and one of our post credits scene we see
Stu Carr and his group of Ravagers that
group of Ravagers is a version of the
original group of the guardians of the
galaxy
it's Kruger and that says that's the the
pronunciation of that character's name
who's a sort of sorcerer from another
planet ease of race of limbs and Charlie
27 played by ving rhames Michelle Yeoh
plays a leader who is stuck our wife and
mainframe played by Miley Cyrus who's a
disembodied head and of course Martin
explained by my friend Michael Rosenbaum
people are asking me are they going to
be in guardians of the galaxy vol 3 so
I'm going to leave that to the
imagination but we'll see what happens
I'm just in the middle of writing vol 3
right now so who knows exactly what's
going to happen what was the decision
process for choosing stack our Aleida
charlie 27 main Frank Krueger and Martin
xoz original guardians it really was
just that was one the only post credit
scene I think that was written after I
had shot the rest of the movie I shot
that in post I woke up one morning and I
was thinking oh my god I would love to
see those guys together at the end of
the movie sort of forming an even more
messed up screwy version of the
Guardians who are even less hick heroic
than the guardians are and that are also
even weirder Charlie 27 is obvious
martynuk is obvious they're two of the
original guardians of the galaxy
Elita I thought was you know an
interesting character mainframe is male
I thought she could be very interesting
as this big tough you know this robot
head that could go and do on a lot of
other things and is but it talks like a
you know like Miley Cyrus and and then
Kruger I just thought was even weirder
than rocketing
could be a really cool character so
breaking down the important stuff James
Gunn writing guardians three right now
obviously Adam warlock is going to be
one of the early builds for that movie
Alicia is going to come back the
sovereign will be big villains he
implies in a roundabout way that Peter
quill will not be coming to Earth during
Avengers infinity war so there's been a
lot of scenes they've been filming with
those characters together with the
guardians and the Avengers characters
that means that will take place in outer
space like it's a promo that I play at
the beginning of this that said a
sanctuary where we saw the guardians
during the first film so guardians
Avengers meeting in outer space but if
you missed it probably the biggest thing
is that he said that he purposefully
tried to use that Stan Lee cameo to
connect the MCU with the Fox x-men films
via that Deadpool cameo that Stan Lee
had did not make the final cut though
but let me know in the comments which
our favorite thing that he revealed
about the movies and infinity war I've
got some new spider-man homecoming I'm
going to try and post on Monday but
congratulations to Dave Slattery you're
the latest giveaway winner please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details while you wait for everything
you can click here for all my Guardians
videos including more post credits and
you can click here for brand new Rick
and Morty thank you so much for watching
+ i-5 I'll see you guys tonight